joining us now to discuss how we got to
where we were able to lift the mass
mandate dr david dijon he is associate
professor at kirk korean school of
medicine over at unlv doctor thank you
so much for joining us today we
appreciate it my pleasure big decline in
omicron as so many physicians talked
about happening with it being more of a
mild and highly transmissible did you
expect it this fast
well this was quite a dramatic peak
and sometimes when you see that you'll
also see a dramatic fall and so that's
somewhat fortuitous we peaked a couple
weeks ago and we clearly are on the way
down now now that the mass are off what
kind of advice can we give to our
viewership and just a reminder about how
transmission happens in terms of covid19
now that so many will not be wearing a
mask well i think it's important to
remember that you know the mask can
still protect the individual and so if
there are people that have underlying
conditions where they may be at higher
risk for developing severe disease
then i would recommend continuing to
wear the mask and certainly in the
settings that we talked about you know
in healthcare settings
in public transportation and other
places you may want to still continue to
wear the mask
doctor recent study about the benefits
of vitamin d which we've heard about
with covet what are some other things we
can tell our viewers to try to raise
their immunity level as they may be
exposed to more germs
well i mean you know just the usual
things we talk about eating well getting
lots of sleep
trying to avoid illnesses illnesses to
the extent that you can
and with this particular disease
just
some of the things we put in place
months ago even actually now a couple
years ago like social distancing
hand washing and wearing of masks are
still important
last question uh for this interview as
we move from pandemic to endemic what is
your advice in terms of if a new variant
does pop up how should we handle it
as we move forward and mutation happens
you know we've we've been here before
we've seen this movie before so you know
we still need to i think be cautious
we're on the way down but the numbers of
cases are still quite high the test
positivity rate is still you know
hovering around 20 percent statewide
and that's a very high number if you
remember when we tried to talk about
opening schools months ago we were
hoping to have positivity rates of less
than five percent so we're way above
that now so we want to still be careful
doctor we appreciate your expertise and
time doctor will be back with us in the
6 p.m hour on 8 news now thank you
doctor my pleasure and